new tributes to ann heishas the actress
is removed from life support nine days
after her car crash welcome to
entertainment tonight michelle turner is
off lauren zema here with me yes and
leaving behind two sons including her
eldest homer with ex coley lefone who is
now breaking his silence in an emotional
new video
i just have been blessed with this
incredible incredible love and
incredible career
[Music]
i loved her and i miss her and i'm
always going to
homer is okay he's grieving and it's
really rough i think ann is probably
i'd like to think she's free free from
pain so goodbye ann thank you for all
the good times there were so many and
see you on the other side and in the
meantime i got our son and he'll be fine
love you
e.t has learned anne was removed from
life support sunday after being declared
brain dead on friday we're told the
decision was made after a compatible
person was found to receive her donated
organs which is something ann wanted i
like life i like life that's what it is
the lapd says haish had narcotics in her
system at the time of the horrific crash
but the investigation it's been
officially called off in the wake of
ann's passing in a statement to e.t
oscar winner robert de niro said she was
a wonderful actress and i enjoyed
working with her tremendously in wag the
dog i thought they let us out of there
too easily ann also starred opposite
johnny depp in donnie brasco and
harrison ford in six days seven nights
but anne's big acting break came on the
nbc soap opera another world playing
twins well then what's your break would
you please let me get a sentence in it's
the hardest work anybody could ever do
there's this saying let go and let god
and that's kind of how i live my life
you know it's just like let go there's a
whole bunch of things out there to
embrace
[Music]
you